[Musique]
j'étais fan toi comment tu apprends ce
qui s'est passé c'est c'est ton papa qui
t'appelle oui m'a appelé dans la nuit
pendant la nuit tu vois un appel à
quelle heure il a commencé à m'appeler
annonce marca place à trois heures du
matin c'est que ton papa déjà est malade
on sait que bernard à 3 heures du matin
tu vois un appel de ton père tu es jacky
study dans ta tête
ben je dormais donc je n'ai pas vu as tu
as pas vu le doxie découvre alors là bas
j'ai découvert à 6h30 et 6h30 tu vois
ton père t'a plusieurs fois où tu vois
pas non parce que le que quand je me
lève je n'allume pas mon téléphone mois
d'avril bref voilà jeu là je prends mon
café et je me mets devant la télé comme
tous les matchs à la télé et oui je la
prends comme ça et c est ma femme m'a
dit mais vite vite viens voir ce qui se
passe et la j'allume le téléphone et
joie 172 appelle des messages de partout
des amis beaucoup d'amis et voilà mais
c'est dur tu vois d'un coup la télé
c'est toi café a du mal à passer
donc là c'est dans la nuit quoi 3 heures
du matin non lui s'il s'est réveillé à
minuit et demi une amie d'accord sont en
train de dormir les autres dans la dans
la misère tous les deux et il se fout à
veiller avec light dans les yeux coups
de batte directs indirects
ils savaient qu'ils allaient chercher
ton par ben oui oui n'était pas étonné
moi la soie nuit par hasard non c'était
pas un hasard et ce avec chez qu'ils
allaient et il avait cet espèce
d'obsession qui hantent apparemment
beaucoup de monde c'est de savoir où
était le coffre fort alors il paraît
donc là il s'attaque d'abord à ton papa
ou d'abord atteint d'abord avons fait à
le mettre ko d'entrée pour être sûr
qu'il bouge pas trop et après sous
occupé de ma belle-mère qui est qui a
été pareil réveillé après l'a été c'est
que les deux l'ont été
attaché mon père a été attaché départ
les mains et les pieds au bout du lit et
ma mère ils ont attaché les mains et il
l'a traînée dans la maison par les
cheveux en en lui hurlant de de montrer
où était le coffre qui amènera de coffre
ah ouais et à chaque fois qu'elle
répondait non elle en prenez donc là
avant moi elle leur dit pas qui a pas de
coffre tient assez basses il y en a pas
mais c'est pas grave ils sont persuadés
qu'il y en a donc pris et ça dure trois
quarts d'heure comme ça sur trois quarts
d'heure un moment ils comprennent qu
après manque pas de coffre ou est ce
qu'il ne sait par quelle magie ils
l'auront met tellement plein la tronche
qui disent qu'à la fin on forcément pas
donc voilà ils partent avec juste une
montre et inba quoi après bah y'en a qui
qui qui finissent par mourir sous les
coups eux non il faut garder positive de
ça voilà c'est que ils les ont laissés
en vie alors à ici par t il les laisse
pas envie les gens s est ce que c'est
vrai que tu as ta belle mère a voulu
protéger aussi ton papa elle a dit voilà
mais c'est le il a décelé tranquille et
c'est moi qui vais vous dire ce qui est
vous voulez et voilà et et problème
c'est qu'en plus il a pris un coup
derrière la tête et comme il a une
nouvelle tumeur dans la tête il avait il
avait très peur que la tumeur expose
donc elle a voulu prendre tout de suite
sa défense voilà comme je suis toujours
dit c est le héros il ya plein de gens
qui qui se demandent pourquoi ton papa a
refusé d'aller à l'hôpital
pourquoi ce qui va revoir les photos
c'est vrai que pourquoi je le chante et
on sait ton frère aussi qu'il a voulu
montrer de photos donc c'est abel mairie
et ton père et bernard il c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué de les regarder
je comprends stefan gp mais c'est bon
c'est ce que tu m'a dit tu m'as dit il
n'a pas voulu y aller parce que parce
que voilà et voulais que ça soit son
médecin ce qui regarde si ces tumeurs
avait pas bougé c'est voilà c'est tout
il n'a pas voulu il n'a pas voulu
ignorer comment ils vont bernard est
donc bien mieux aux gens bien mieux aux
ja ça va déjà un peu mieux dans m
ça va bien mieux physiquement ça va
moins bien face à va toujours pas
terrible moralement mais bon c'est dur
c'est dur voilà en tout cas stéphane
merci d'avoir été là mais tu es comme tu
disais mon frère donc j'ai comptes m
le fait et on fait des noms bisou à
bernard et dominique voilà et on t'aime
et tu reviens nous voir quand tu veux
bien entendu ici c'est chez toi merci
pour ce témoignage va faire si mon chéri
tu sais qu'on t'aime et qu'on est
toujours là et j'espère que vous allez
pouvoir aussi vous reposer un peu et
ouais on va les faire un gros dodo
ouais exactement